(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] According to the UN,
Africa is one of the most vulnerable
continents to climate change,
due to it's poverty levels,
scarce water sources,
and rain-fed farmland.
Farmers here in Kenya are being forced
to look for new, more
drought-resistant options
to grow when traditional crops fail.
This is where sisal comes in.
Sisal is built for harsher climates.
Under it's green exterior
are strong fibers
that are useful in making
all sorts of things.
There's just one problem.
This was Alex's first invention.
It can strip sisal fibers in seconds.
These fibers can be sold
for 20 shillings per kilo.
But this wasn't enough for Alex.
This machine turns the fibers into rope,
which adds value of almost 180%.
The rope can be used to
make a variety of items,
like bags and mats.
(upbeat music)